there is a litigation attorney that is
offering five thousand dollars to any
woman that can find her a husband
she is offering a five thousand dollar
bonus
let's pull up the video king
so I'm at the spot with my boss like a
couple years ago and I've now added my
best friend her husband and a couple
other friends but I feel like I'm just
gonna open it up to the general public
because I'm good for it so the backslash
offers if you introduce me to my husband
and I marry him I will give you five
thousand dollars I don't have to say
married to him for long I can get
divorced in 20 years it doesn't matter
but if you introduce me to a man that I
walk down the aisle and get married to I
will give you five thousand dollars my
DMs are open do you notice how she says
I don't have to be married to him for
long
this is the mindset women want the
wedding more than they want the marriage
she doesn't do you hear that she doesn't
even care about being married to this
man for long all she wants is a husband
now let's let's go through her
requirements I bet they're very
deep and like I I bet you know they're
very reasonable okay at 35 being a 35
year old litigation attorney knowing
knowing that what you bring to a
marriage at 35 years old is in all
honesty nothing even if you're a hottie
which she seems like an all right
looking chick you know even if you're a
big hottie at 35 most men get married
because they want children
I would you ever get married if no kids
were involved no see the guys are
shaking their head so women know this
right the men look at you and they gotta
think could this woman raise some kids
right and if you're not bringing
children to the table
most men don't really see the point of
marriage so at 35
geriatric pregnancy starts that year
so her odds of even having kids like
first she has to get to know her so
it'll be like till 37 right most men
want to get how long you want to get in
get to know a girl before marrying her
like one to two years yeah roughly okay
so now it's 37 she's pushing 40.
and that's really you really a
depreciate and asset at that point so
you know at this point you would think
she would be desperate now like let's I
really want to ask ladies at what age
should we be desperate like why is
desperation why is it always labeled as
a bad thing sometimes desperate times
the men know this right desperate times
if they're really broke if they just
aren't looking the best they might date
a whale for a bit
you know what I mean they might marry an
ugly chick like men understand
that really in all honesty when you
think about it all men are in desperate
times when you think about it when you
think about it all men have really
adapted to the times okay because a
hundred years ago what would the man so
the man would come to the table and he
said here's your protection here's your
provisioning now a hundred years later
men still by and large outer in women
men still by and large run society and
they run all of the mechanisms that
protect women in society so women are
still getting the protection and
provisioning and before the men would
get like five kids out of the deal and
exchange they would get a virgin or at
least a chick that hadn't slept with
like I mean 85 percent of women said
they were virgins on their wedding night
let's just say some were lying still
still two out of three even if it was 50
that's better than today all right and
so they would know all right my girl
hasn't been with that many guys
and they would get
femininity a girl that wanted to stay
home raise the kids now
what do men get
a girl that has a high body count the
average woman's 170 pounds
five four
men understood you know what this is
what the Market's giving us we're
adapting to the times now women at 35
years old
still won't adapt to the market she
can't find the 511 dude that wants her
that she finds attractive so it might be
time to be desperate why is desperation
always a bad thing you know what I mean
now
she also said she's been on the dating
apps for five years now the issue you're
going to have on dating apps is that
women only swipe right on dating apps
five percent of the time so if you're
going on a date on a dating app as a
woman you're probably at a disadvantage
not because you're at a disadvantage
throughout all of dating apps but the
guy you're on a date with probably
has a ton of options and isn't going to
treat you very special all right I'm
just I'm just being honest because the
guys that we tend to swipe on have all
the women are swiping on so I don't know
if dating apps are the best you know way
but whatever so
she said so I feel like paying five
thousand dollars for a husband who's
vouched for meets my needs and is ready
for a real relationship is totally worth
it do you notice how she didn't say
anything she would bring she said he has
to meet my needs but what about you
meeting his needs but this is the thing
women will get to society has told us
chase the career be successful whatever
and she did that and she makes it to 35
years old never having once thought
about what men want
and this is why the red pill is so
important because we go through our
whole lives never having even heard what
men want
she also said can't be his second wife
lady like
you're ruling out you're 35 years old
and you're going to rule out men because
they've been married before
and then the second thing is that
5 11 or taller nowhere did you hear
anything about character did you hear
anything about values
in fact she doesn't care about political
beliefs
religious beliefs
or ethnicity so
nothing about culture nothing about
values 5 11 can never have been married
before and he has to meet my needs and
we wonder why marriage sucks today when
in the last 100 years we have had more
mate selection than ever women have had
more freedom in the last 100 years to
choose husbands and partners and you
know what we suck at it we are
absolutely terrible we don't know what
we want we just pick for looks and the
funny thing is
she says a 35 year old woman says
Hollywood heartthrobs these are these
are examples of the men she would want
Gossip Girl star Chuck Bass Oscar
winning Matthew McConaughey
so you tell me is this reasonable
is that do you think this is a
reasonable list you know I I appreciate
that she's bringing money to the table
but it's funny how women it's like our
solution is to pay people to do work for
us instead of putting in the work to
becoming better wives and mothers
instead of learning skills that would
give us the outcome we want it's funny
because they'll call men in cells in the
red pill right they'll see all these red
pill men or just in cells they can't get
women a lot of men will agree and say
you know what I can't get women I'm
broken I'm fat
and they'll take a path towards
Improvement but where are all the real
women's improvement classes genuinely I
don't see them I see women going to some
feminist therapist that makes us worse
okay I I see us going to some feminist
therapists that just makes us worse
people
going to the gym a bit posting some
selfies on Instagram learning how to do
your makeup a little better and then
slap in a selfie on Instagram saying
I've healed oh and taking a trip to
Aruba
yes I forgot about the trip to Aruba
where they just learned to be the best
version of ourselves a wife a mother and
yeah that that's what I see but the men
I at least see improving
you know there's many testimonials from
guys like fresh and fit and all these
other self-improvement guys where they
get in better shape
they make more money have you seen a
self-improvement like women losing
weight and cookbooks and like going back
to more traditional values and the funny
thing is men are much more traditional
than women nowadays yet the
conservatives and the Trad cons will say
oh well the men just need to be better
they need to be better when it's like
all right men pay 80 percent of the
taxes men run the entire infrastructure
of society which one out of two men is
in an industry that runs the
infrastructure so protection and
provisioning from a societal standpoint
men are doing more
um the women are the ones that aren't
holding a bar into the bargain
are we're having 1.4 children or 1.2
roughly we're not even having an average
of two kids it's like all right so the
men pay all the taxes they run the
entire infrastructure of society they
have made systems that protect us like
the police the military and the judicial
system that'll also protect us and all
they want in return is some kids and we
can't even do that is the crazy thing
and then they want to get mad at me for
pointing things out and saying you know
what Trad cons I don't think women and
men are offering equal value to society
I don't think women are helping run
Society I think nowadays we have less
value and the funny thing is the oh the
funny thing is
these ladies will come in and say I am
tradcon but if you went to college
you cannot be you can't be traditional
because college is a feminist
Institution for Women yes if you look at
the birth rate and the rate of women
having children
it's in verse
they're trying to program us to not have
this is the crazy thing now my point is
this
why do we have a society that is always
focused on the men and the men need to
be better but never the women and if
anyone says anything about the women
they get attacked mercilessly
maybe I'm crazy though I don't know
maybe I just don't know what I'm talking
about I'm just grifting making some
things up I I'm just I'm just
reiterating what I see